Chris is with us in Raleigh North
Carolina starting off this hour
hey Chris how are you hi Dave it's not
her to speak with you you too sir how
can I help
just a little background I'm in the
military and I have zero debt and have
been able to max out both my Ross GSP
and my Roth IRA for the past few years
look at you I am why thank you just two
recent events one I got recently engaged
and then two I recently found out I'm
getting deployed to the Middle East
so my fiance has about $90,000 in debt
and the plan is to get married right
after I come back from deployment so my
question is should I just stop
contributing to my retirement and just
save as much money as you can especially
more so if I'm getting deployed just to
drop all that to her debt once we get
married or continue to save the
retirement and just save additional
whatever else is left until we
officially get married now whoom so when
do you leave right here in a couple
weeks okay thank you for your service so
you're going before go ahead and before
Christmas huh yes sir Wow
and when will you be back should be
about July and planning to get married
in August okay excellent yeah so we're
talking six months or so eight months
yes sir and yeah I definitely would stop
and be in preparation for this marriage
and be in preparation to throw money at
that 90 how much can you pile up if we
do that if I do that I'm thinking
between 4550 awesome awesome so you're
gonna knock this thing in the head
pretty quick and how much can she throw
at it during that time well with her
kind of save up for the wedding cost as
well I'm thinking she'd be able to put
an additional thousand a month towards
it okay so there's no help on the
wedding no okay and what is the nature
of the $90,000 in debt it's about 70 in
student loans and 20 in a car sometime
what does she make a year she makes
about 65 as a nurse and beefy okay all
right well she's pretty rich in that car
pretty hanging on that car I mean it's
on the bubble I mean you guys are
getting married so you can choose to
keep it on our ratios that we use but
it's not a it's not thrilling now here's
the big question you guys have had the
debt talk right yes we have and so where
is she on all this she is completely on
board never borrow money again ever
exactly sir that is the plan okay
because I know that's your plan and it's
because you've done a great job of
handling money I mean you're really on
beat and if you marry somebody who's
bent on spending it it's gonna be a
rough marriage no sir no sir she wants
to get rid of debt as well and
definitely playing on signing up a few
once we do get married okay very cool
very cool well congratulations and yes I
I would do your plan which is stop all
savings and pile up cash as high as you
can pile it especially you got the
tax-free money from being deployed I
assume you're going to sandbox yes sir I
am yeah so you'll be do you get combat
pay still there tax-free yes there good
good I'm glad
okay yeah just pile up as much of that
as you can pile up and and you know then
when you can return let's see how hard
we can hit that student loan then of
course on marriage get back from the
honeymoon we attack again and finish off
the debt and just work your baby steps
then and work it work it as fast as you
can and as hard as you can so good stuff
man thank you for your call hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
now
[Music]